sir today is Downing Street press
conference I'm pleased to be joined
today by dr. Jenny Harris let me start
by updating you on the latest
information from the government's cobra
data file as of today three million
three hundred and forty-eight thousand
five hundred and seven tests for
coronavirus have now been carried out in
the UK including one hundred and sixteen
thousand five hundred and eighty five
tests yesterday two hundred and fifty
seven thousand one hundred and fifty
four people have tested positive that's
an increase of two thousand nine hundred
and fifty nine cases since yesterday
nine thousand three hundred and thirty
one people are currently in hospital
with coronavirus down eleven percent
since last week and tragically 36
thousand six hundred and seventy five
people have now died that's an increase
of two hundred and eighty two fatalities
since yesterday and that's across all
settings this is not just a list of
Statistics of course but a devastating
reminder of the cruelty of coronavirus
our thoughts are with friends and the
families of the victims as we start to
relax the restrictions we must plan our
route to recovery allowing people to
resume their lives where possible
getting businesses up and running again
and building beyond coronavirus in the
short term will bring will need to bring
back more public transport to keep
families safe that process has already
begun rail and tube services increased
at the beginning of this week and the
ramped up more next month and to ensure
that more buses trams and light rail
networks return to service today I can
announce new investment of two hundred
and eighty three million pounds to start
moving back to a full timetable however
I do want to stress this funding does
not mean we can go back to using public
transport whenever we like remember
those who can should still work from
home those who can should still avoid
all public transport even a fully
restored service will only be capable of
carrying at best one-fifth of the normal
capacity once social distancing is taken
into account so only if you need to
travel and you can't cycle or walk or
drive should you take a bus tram or
train but please avoid the rush hour
we're managing the transport network to
make it as safe as possible this week we
saw the deployment of nearly three and a
half thousand British Transport Police
Network Rail and Transport for London
employees these marshals worked with the
public to prevent services from becoming
overcrowded from June 1st at the
earliest as we move to phase 2 of the
unlock will start to deploy twice as
many marshals with the assistance of
groups like the charity volunteering
matters these journey makers will help
provide reassurance advice and friendly
assistance to commuters the last time we
did this at the 2012 Olympics it was a
great success and while these are
altogether more serious times if we show
the same public spirit of concern for
one another it will go a long way
towards helping Transport and passengers
cope as I've said it's essential we
stagger our journeys and avoid the rush
hour that's why at a recent roundtable
we asked the tech sector to come up with
innovative proposals to help passengers
avoid congestion one good example is
passenger connect from Birmingham
startup zip about a personalized
information service which tells rail
users how disruption and crowding may
affect their journey while providing
alternatives and helping people to
maintain social distancing the service
has been successfully piloted over the
past 12 months and it will be rolled out
soon
we're not just stealing with the immense
challenges of the present were building
for the future two transports not just
about how he get from place to place it
also shapes the places for good or bad
towns cities and whole nations we now
have an opportunity to use the power of
transport to improve long-standing
national weaknesses and create something
better
the UK's unbalanced economy is one such
weakness our mission is to level up
Britain the co vid outbreak must be the
catalyst to get it done leveling up and
speeding up so while roads and railways
are less busy we're accelerating vital
projects take the north for example this
bank holiday weekend we're carrying out
vital work to fix Leeds Station
continuing to build a new platform
installing new points and switches and
improving the track to Wakefield just
part of 490 separate engineering
projects happening around the country
this bank holiday weekend work that
would normally take months of weekend
closures much quicker on these quieter
railways and we're getting on with plans
to reverse some of the so-called
beaching rail cuts to doctor beaching
wrote a report back in the 1960s which
led to the closure of one third of our
railway network 2363 stations 5,000
miles of track identified for closure
many of the places removed from the map
never recovered that report was perhaps
the origin of the left behind town but
we're working to reverse beaching the
process has already started in Blyth in
the Northeast and fleetwood in the
northwest I visited in January and also
took the opportunity to visit Horton
Peter Lee to see the station building
work there used to be a train station
200 yards away but it was closed in the
town cut off by the Beeching axe this
new station will connect a community of
over 50,000 people
improving their quality of life and
today the next 10 schemes to benefit are
announced its development funding but if
they stack up then we're going to build
them fast amongst the many schemes is
the reinstatement of the Ivanhoe line in
these Midlands from Leicester to Burton
Barr Colville and Ashby and branch lines
on the Isle of Wight and a new station
at Wellington in Somerset but no matter
how great we make the railways of the
future millions will still rely on the
car that's why today I'm publishing the
preferred route to complete the dual
carriageway on the a 66 from Scotch
corner to Penrith the first new all dual
carriageway across the Pennines
in 50 years this is a 1 billion pound
program that will transform the capacity
by upgrading junctions and widening the
road these road and rail schemes will be
the first of many binding our country
together connecting people with jobs but
it isn't just the balance between
regions that we need to reshape it's
hard to see millions who until a few
weeks ago commuted by train into
Manchester London Birmingham every day
will immediately go back to the same old
ways so we have to reshape our towns and
cities to the Prime Minister once said
cities aware inspiration and innovation
happens because people can bump into
each other
spark off one another compete
collaborate invent and innovate that's
when we get the explosion or flash of
creativity and innovation and yet with
social distancing it makes all that
rather more difficult so we have to find
new ways of making it happen
therefore as conditions allow and not
until July we'll be looking to support
creative ways for businesses to reopen
whilst maintaining social distancing we
know restaurants and bars will want to
start trading again and we'll work with
them so we can enjoy an outdoor summer
in a safe and responsible
for those who live to faster cycle and
walk and must drive to major
conurbations will repurpose parking in
places just outside town centers so
people can park on the outskirts and
finish their journeys on foot or bike or
even e-scooter our aim with these
measures is not merely to get through
the lifting of restrictions and then
return to how things were but to come
out of this recovery stronger by
permanently changing the way we use
transport take the bike for example
previously we announced the introduction
of a scheme to help bring bicycles back
into a roadworthy condition relieving
the pressure on public transport and
improving the nation's health today I
can provide the detail of the new
50-pound bycel bicycle maintenance
voucher available from next month the
scheme will help up to half a million
people drag bikes out of retirement
speeding up the cycling revolution
helping individuals become fitter and
healthier and reducing air pollution
which remains a hidden killer clean air
should be as big a priority for us in
the 21st century as clean water whilst
of the Victorians use trains buses and
trams safely more commuters to take up
active travel and more people to benefit
from infrastructure improvements in the
northern powerhouse and across the
country they gave us all an opportunity
to harness the power of transport not
just to help us return to the lives in
the post kovat world but to make our
economy more resilient our population
healthier and to change our nation for
the better